[Music]
we thought that elements cannot be
clearly classified into metals and
nonmetals based on their physical
properties with chemical properties help
let's understand chemical properties of
metals first when you're looking at
chemical properties of metals there are
a few things we will look at we will see
what happens when metals are burnt in a
when metals react with water when metals
react with acids and lastly when metals
react with solutions of other metal
salts now in all these four categories
there's just one simple thing we will do
we will look at how reactive the metals
are if the metals react easily may it be
with oxygen or air or anything else we
say that they are more reactive well
it's more difficult for them to react we
say that they are less reactive let's
focus on the first category metals burnt
in air the most important points to note
here is that almost all metals react
with oxygen to form metal oxides these
metal oxides that are formed are usually
basic but they can also be amphoteric
what do we mean by amphoteric metal
oxides which may show acidic as well as
basic behaviors are known as amphoteric
oxides most metal oxides are insoluble
in water but some may also dissolve to
form alkalis okay so metal oxides being
formed in one thing but do all metals
react with oxygen at the same rate not
really different metals show different
levels of reactivity towards oxygen
alkali metals such as sodium and
potassium react vigorously with oxygen
in fact they react even if they are just
kept in the open that is at room
temperature they don't even need fire to
ignite the reaction what about the other
metals metals such as magnesium
aluminium zinc and lead
also react with oxygen at room
temperature but they react a bit
differently when they react with oxygen
their surfaces get covered with a thin
protective layer of oxide this layer
protects the inner part from being
oxidized
what about iron iron doesn't burn on
heating but iron fillings burned
vigorously after being heated and which
metals do we have at the end of the
spectrum yes silver and gold can you
guess how they react with oxygen when
burnt silver and gold do not react with
oxygen at all yes they don't react even
at high temperatures so we see somewhat
of a pattern event amongst the metals
sodium and potassium are more reactive
whereas magnesium is relatively less
reactive but wait burning in oxygen
doesn't really help us to decide about
the reactivity of zinc ion lead or
copper all we know about these four is
that they form a thin layer of oxide
around the metals such as this category
of burning metals in air isn't enough
for us to judge the order of reactivity
of these metals we can see a few more
reactions to judge the order of
reactivity so in the next lesson we will
see how metals react with water
you